what up guys its goals in here and we're
going to be vlogging playing pokemon go
today we're actually going to go to
Brock University and I'm waiting in the
car for an imac who's driving and i just
want to give you guys a tip sometimes
leave your phone on in the car you'll
get some kilometers you know cars stop
and go and it alot up over time I might
even hatch an egg in the car we'll see
okay guys like I said keep it on in the
car we got an egg that's about the hatch
let's see what it is it's a 2k Magikarp
that's good and bad like I'm excited
about the gyarados but I'm so far away
all they have for you on campus how many
eggs be good how many eggs I'll just
want hatched so how many eggs that you
get with it rock candy sour candies I
only got like 10 I like of candy so it's
a long way to go together so guys as
soon as we sat down two morons opened up
our pokemon go looked around we saw how
many gems there where I brought on many
focused stops I mean Brock is definitely
a Pokemon hotspot and I saw some crazy
poke lon including a dragon knight
defending one of the gyms
i zoomed in to get a closer look and
then I saw that it was 2547 CT some like
man we had to take that guy down
alright guys so goes in just took over
for Jim's by himself because he's such a
super Pokemon nerd so let's see what he
how he feels right now gold xau do you
feel yeah we took over every Brock gym
for mystic feels pretty pretty cool i
know ones crazy enough to be out in this
heat that's probably why i like we're
still holding them but man yeah we took
over Brock we took it over yeah like to
be fair it was it was only you because
I'm team instinct but I don't play that
much so my Pokemon suck so mr. goes on
over there took over all four for his uh
mystic buddies the mainstream team you
know what I mean the mainstream team I
was just really sweaty right now uh yeah
it's really hot day it's good work man
it's so right now we're at this park
we're gonna hatch some eggs do some
evolutions I'm putting lucky egg without
on right now and then we're gonna see
how much I can level up and you guys are
gonna get to see some cool evolutions
and we're both in for a surprise as to
what the eggs will be let's walk so much
fun so much
guys where it does this is the 10k egg
we're gonna hatch right now okay you
ready for this what's it gonna be Oh
what's gonna be it's just a Sandman I'm
just recording here right snarl ox
what's the fears are gonna be it's a new
pope a question about the film it will
have it on the street honey 1774 it's my
life oh let dream come true right now
awesome I'm site and hyper beam is a
special 120 oh it's gonna be great and a
port I love lots of 22 right now nice
Oh another guy's what an amazing day for
Pokemon catching we later got a
bellsprout egg and that ended up putting
me over the 100 and then I could evolve
my weepinbell into a victreebel I also
hatched a ghastly and I'm closer to
evolve my haunter into a gengar we also
had Geodude and the Geodude is now
grappler and we also had two star me
which I needed whilst are you sorry and
as the star me we have now and Tessa's
up at Jim's Snorlax hyper beam it's
quite amazing as is victory belt solar
beam so do you guys like this video give
us a like and definitely stay tuned for
more pokemon gold logging and let's see
what happens next